long before you became Drake the famous
rapper we all know and love
when this award is just unbelievable as
surreal and you used to go by the name
of Aubrey Graham but you were mostly
known for your acting skills instead of
your rapping skills it's not that your
rap was bad at first it was hard for
fans to stop referring to you as Jimmy
Brooks the school's basketball star who
is paralyzed from the waist down after
an unfortunate run-in with Rick but
nowadays you're the one and only Drake
some of the actors who starred in the
hit TV series Degrassi the next
generation have gone on to star in big
productions some have even garnered
household names but others found it
challenging to shed their Degrassi past
and take on new projects which is why
they changed their career paths
completely watch until the end to find
out which Degrassi stars are still
acting today how is everyone Lauren
Collins Paige and Michael Chuck the
Queen V of Degrassi left a huge
impression on her fans making her one of
the most beloved characters the show had
to offer
Lauren hasn't stopped acting since she
left the Degrassi cast on top of
producing three short films lauren
starred in the youtube original series
impulse she has also been cast as Kate
in seriously let's make one thing clear
I am NOT famous Adamo Ruggero
valedictorian Marco de Rossi was
portrayed by Adama Ruggero who starred
on Degrassi from 2002 to 2009 in real
life Adamo is still good friends with
his on-screen besties Lauren Collins
Adamo has also starred in a handful of
short films since leaving the show he
snagged a few one-time roles in TV shows
like saving Hope beam Erica and
fabulosity the musically gifted Craig
Manning was portrayed by actor Jake
Epstein who went on to become a Broadway
star after leaving the cast of Degrassi
Jake went to acting school and made his
Broadway debut in spider-man turn off
the dark he also starred as Brian Altman
in the hit TV series suits Efrem Ellis
efrem Ellis is notorious for playing
Rick Murray the character responsible
for putting Jimmy Brooks in a wheelchair
after Degrassi Ephram continued to
pursue an acting career and landed roles
in TV series like Falcon Beach Murdoch
mysteries and family biz in his spare
time Ephraim enjoys hanging out with his
cats and watching Star Wars because I'm
awesome
Miriam MacDonald Mary McDonald starred
as Emma Nelson and nine seasons of
Degrassi she Simpson reprised her role
on the TV show Degrassi takes Manhattan
and in an episode of Degrassi next class
Miriam has also appeared in a single
episode of orphan black and lost girl
she is currently making rounds as a
social-media influencer and Instagram
model I'm Angie smile olivia Scriven 22
year-old Olivia Scriven is known for
portraying Maya Matlin in the later
seasons of Degrassi on top of reprising
her role as Maya in Degrassi next class
and Degrassi TV
olivia has also appeared in films like
black Conflux blood-quantum
and giant little ones okay well this
dumb music stuff is my dream sick Sara
bearable to shower Sara is known for
playing the overachiever liberty vans
end on Degrassi from 2001 to 2009 Sara
hasn't acted in anything but Degrassi
productions
she graduated from Concordia University
in Montreal and went on to become a DJ
and a freelance marketing consultant
she's an activist who fights for what
she believes in would have sweetie I'm a
busy woman cut to the chase
AJ saadon AJ has come a long way from
playing this socially awkward Connor
DeLaurier
he hasn't starred in any production
since leaving the cast of Degrassi in
2015 AJ has been focusing on his career
instead on top of having his Instagram
game down pat AJ has also released a few
tracks as well as an EP like that
Shane Kipple I am a shaky ball Gavin
spinner Mason
Shane is known for portraying the bad
boys spinner Mason on Degrassi for a
total of 13 seasons but since leaving
the cast in 2014 Shane hasn't delved any
further into the acting business
Shane dabbles in stand-up comedy and
earns his keep by drumming for the band
dear love Stacy Farber Stacy Farber who
played Ellie Nash on Degrassi is one of
most successful stars from the show
since leaving Degrassi in 2008 stacy has
gone on to appear in TV series like
Grayson Frankie Animal Kingdom and shits
Creek unprofessional
Charlotte Arnold the popular Holly J
Sinclair was portrayed by Charlotte
Arnold who continue to pursue the Arts
after leaving Degrassi in 2012 before
landing the role of Holly Charlotte
played savvy Hawthorne on the TV series
naturally Sadie nowadays Charlotte has
been cast as Anna in the upcoming film
tasting love Drake
although Drake prefers to focus on his
music career he enjoys putting his
acting skills to good use when the
timing is right Drake has hosted
Saturday Night Live on two occasions he
also voiced Ethan an ice age continental
drift with five studio albums and a
handful of Grammys to his name Drake is
the most successful Degrassi star ever
it's a beautiful thing
Cassie still just like Drake Cassie it's
one of the more successful actors out of
the Degrassi brunch celebrities a pretty
strong word in itself she voices Tammy
on the hit cartoon Rick and Morty in
2020 Cassie will voice Raya in Raya and
the last dragon Nina Dobrev and last but
certainly not least is the beautiful and
talented Nina Dobrev who played Mia
Jones on Degrassi until 2009 Nina has
become the most successful actress to
have ever graced the halls of Degrassi
high she starred as Katherine Pierce in
The Vampire Diaries for eight seasons
and has appeared in films like The Perks
of Being a Wallflower and Dog Days Nina
has recently been cast as Ren in the
upcoming movie sick girl which Degrassi
star as your favorite sound off in the
comments what the cast of Degrassi is
doing right now for more fun videos like
this one subscribe to the things and hit
that thumbs up button while you're at it
thanks for watching we'll see you soon
[Music]